كما ذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه انها
نجحت في صدري سبع محاولات روسيه لتقدم في
مقاطعه دنيا محاوله واحده
اليات في قصف طال موقع عسكريا روسيا عند
مدينه هولديكا في مقاطعه دونيسك
يبقى سخنه محاور القتال في دنياك مع تاكيد
تلك المصادر تمكن القوات الاوكرانيه من صد
جميع المحاولات الروسيه للتقدم على هذا
المحور
اليوم كما اصيب خمسه اخرون في قصف روسيا
طلع عده مدن وبلدات في المقاطعه
انا نائب رئيس المجلس الاقليمي في
خرسانيوري سوبوليب سكينا القوات الروسيه
لا تغادر في الوقت الحالي 20 الى
25,000 من المقاتلين الروس ما زالوا في
الضفه الشماليه لنهر دنبر في خرسون
القوه المسلحه الاوكرانيه
كبيره على محور خاصه
قولها الى التيار الكهربائي والمياه
انقطعت عن نحو مدن وبلدات في المقطعه وذلك
بسبب ما وصفته بالعمل التخريبي
من جهته قال المتحدث باسمي هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه الاكسندرفت بون ان القوه
الروسيه تواصل تدمير قوارب المدنيين
الخاصه على نهر دنبرو في خرسا وادفع
المتحدث ان القوات الروسيه اعطت موعدا
نهائيا لسكان منطقه برسلاف لمغادرتها في
وذلك في العاشره من نوفمبر الجاري
الروسيه
في خرسون يتم تدمير القوارب الخاصه بشكل
جماعي على ضفاف نهر درو كما يتم الاستلام
على الممتلكات الاخرى
اغراق السفن المدنيه يتسرب جزء من الوقود
في ذلك النهار ويهدد بشكل مباشر الوطني
يعني العاشر من نوفمبر بعد ثلاثه ايام
استعجلت انا على العموم الان من كرامات
تورسك معنى مراسلنا عامر لافي اذا عامر
اهلا وسهلا بك يا همنا نعرف منك اخر
التطورات الميدانيه في الشرق خاصه تفضل
تبقى هي الجبهه الاسخن على طول خطوط
المواجهه في مقاطعه دونيس نتحدث عن سبع
مناطق كان فيها اشتباكات خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه وفقا لقياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
انما تبقى مدينه محمود هي الاسخن واضح ان
هناك نوع من الاستماته من قبل القوات
الروسيه للسيطره على هذه المدينه التي
تمكنت من السيطره عليها فسيكون الجميع
يعلم بان الطريق سيكون مفتوح ربما نوعا ما
امام القوات الروسيه للسيطره على المدن
الاستراتيجيه في مقاطعه يعني طبعا هناك
كرامات تورس كالعاصمه المؤقته وايضا مدينه
سلوفيانوس وبالتالي يدرك الاوكرانيين ذلك
تدرك الان قياده العسكريه هذه الحقيقه
وبالتالي علمنا من مصادر اوكرانيه بانه
هناك تعزيزات بدا يتصل بالفعل الى هذه
المنطقه لصد هذه الهجمه على مدينه محمود
طبعا كنا بالامس في هذه المدينه دخلنا هذه
المدينه بصعوبه المدينه يعني يمكنني ان
اقول ليلى بان الحياه كانت متوقفه بالفعل
في هذه المدينه لا يوجد اي نوع من الخدمات
الاساسيه فيها
الاصوات القصائد القذائف والقصف لا تتوقف
في هذه المدينه جزء كبير من مبانيها قد
دمر جراء هذا القصف يوميا هناك قتلى في
صفوف المدنيين علما بان معظم سكانها
تركوها والسلطات هناك تحاول وتناشد ان يتم
اخلاء المدينه بسبب هذا القصف في المستمر
لكن ما زال هناك بعض السكان وخصوصا من
كبار السن يرفضون مغادره هذه المدينه على
صعيد اخر قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه تحدث
عن انتصارات
بخصوص الضربات المؤلمه كما تصفها بالقصف
المدفعي من خلال كما يبدو طبعا
وسائل الدفاعيه والاسلحه الاجنبيه التي
وصلت الى الاوكرانيين الحديث هنا من قياده
همم
العسكريه الاوكرانيه عن استهداف تجمع
عمليات في اا قرب مدينه يورليكا في داخل
دونيس والحديث هنا عن اعطاب خمسه اليات عن
تدمير عفوا خمسه اليات واعطاب اربعه في
هذا المكان وايضا في مكان قريب من هذا
التجمع وتحديدا في بلده مايورست هناك حديث
من قياده الاركان والتاكيد انها تمكنت من
قتل 30 جنديا روسيا واصابه 120 ايضا في
نفس هذا المكان ايضا الحديث عن استهداف
لتجمع للقوات الروسيه في شانز اذن نحن
نتحدث عن لجانسكي الان والحديث بالقياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه عن مقتل 30 واصابه 15
من كتيبه اخماد هذه الكتيبه ليله هي كتيبه
المقاتلين الشيشانيين الذين يتبعون قدراف
وهي جزء طبعا من القوات الروسيه الحديث عن
مقتل خمسه عشر من هذه من جنود هذه الكتيبه
في الاساس التي كانت القوات الروسيه كما
تعلمين قد سيطرت عليها في تموز الماضي
ايضا هناك طبعا على الرغم من ان معظم
الجبهات الاسخن هي في لكن ايضا القتال ما
زال مستمرا في الجناح الاخر لاقليم دون
باس يعني هنا لوجانز هناك محاوله من
القوات الروسيه للصيطره على بلوغريكا وهي
بلده تتمكنت القوات الاوكرانيه من استعاده
السيطره عليها مؤخرا لكن قوات روسيه تريد
استعادتها المكان الاخر ايضا المهم هو
محور كريمنا سفاتوفا هذا المحور الذي تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه ويؤكد ايضا حاكم لجامس
بان هناك التقدم ولو كان بطيئا ما زال
مستمر على هذه الجبهه تعلمين بعد الانسحاب
السريع للقوات الروسيه في شمال تونس وشرق
وغرب عفوا لوكاس وصلت وصلت قتال الى هذا
المحور وبدا يصبح بطيئا لكن حاكم لوكاس
يقول بان ما زال هناك تقدم وهناك واضح ان
هناك تعزيزات تصل بشكل كبير الى القوات
الروسيه في هذه المنطقه هناك كميه كبيره
من الالغام تزرع محيط هذه المنطقه لانه
هناك ادراك من اجانب الروسي كما يقول ان
انقل عن حاكم لوجانز بانه اذا ما تمكنت
القوات الاوكرانيه من السيطره على هذا
المحور فسيكون ايضا الطريق سهل ومفتوح نحو
مدن مهمه جدا واعلى هنا طبعا مدينه سفر
ودونيسكو ومدينه لوسيشنز احدى اكبر المدن
في مقاطعه لوغانس وهي التي كانت القوات
الروسيه الروسيه قد سيطرت عليها في قبل
شهرين في حزيران وفي تموز المانيا